chris cornell he seemed like a you know
i had him on the show a couple of times
what a great [ __ ] guy
and i know you were close with him the
guy was such a good
guy like he he really pulled for your
band and for you
that must have been a horrible loss for
you i mean it's sad it's
so [ __ ] sad um
so i got taken away that second there um
you know
i was what was going through your head
that you got taken away
you know i was saying i i grew up with
three brothers and in about a year
um before what happened with with chris
um we got a call at four in the morning
and it was my other brother
and he was telling me that um
our third youngest brother um named
chris
uh he had been spending a lot of time in
africa kind of going back and forth but
kind of almost nine months a year in
africa he was doing some good work and
environmental stuff and had a decent job
and some
and was part of a cool community and
then he was
doing something a bit risky and a bit of
a climbing accident
and he was no longer with us and
um that one took me down so hard and my
brothers and my mom
and uh
i seriously didn't know if i was gonna
get out of that one
and and it really hurt me
to think of what my daughters were
witnessing but there was no hiding it
and it was a dark place and i just
couldn't
deal with the reality and
when it happened with chris
um i gotta say i
i don't i still don't think i've i've
had to be
somewhat in denial and one
one way i was even able to do it and and
it's not i don't even feel like i had a
choice
i just like i was terrified where i
would go
if i allowed myself to feel
what i needed to feel or what i was
instinctively wanting to feel or if i
how dark i felt like i was gonna go
and because i didn't see him that often
in the last 10 years probably only like
four or five times and usually at a gig
or something you know
um
i just kind of i still haven't quite
dealt with it or
you know i'll get stronger as time goes
and and
you know but i i you know we were
close you know and it wasn't just
because we were playing music or what we
were you know neighbors we would do
i would hang out with him outside of the
band more than you know
even the other band guys and i didn't
know that many people in seattle
so we would go on you know crazy hiking
adventures or
we'd go mountain biking or we would
chase the dog in the rain with
drinking shitty beer and you know and it
was cool because
it had nothing to do with anything like
being around other music people
or being around or some kind of la life
or something it was just cool like wow
this is what a
this is what like a quote-unquote like
like a
seems like legit rock star right this is
what he's doing he's chasing a dog in
the rain
with his buddy on a saturday night with
a 12-pack of schmidt
i thought there was a beautiful thing
that you taught chris cornell's daughter
to uh surf i i i can't think of
something better than that that you took
something that you love
you know and you shared it with her it
was before any some of that heavy stuff
happened
and and that was just they were in the
neighborhood but
that's his oldest daughter that we've
grown up with in seattle and
tremendous tremendous girl she's
she's a badass and uh she's been kind of
like a big sister
to my kids and yeah she took it up
pretty good
she was getting wave that's it